what on earth is NASA management
spending our billions of dollars in
taxpayer money on you may have seen the
headlines go around the world this
weekend on how NASA has once again
cancelled another mission to go to the
moon and this of course involved the
prospector rover mission which was going
to conduct experiments as a direct
precursor to sending human beings to the
moon once again in this video I have a
few really interesting points to make
about this situation and I'm also going
to share with you the actual person
involved in NASA management who
cancelled this mission now like I said
NASA scientists are absolutely shocked
that this mission was canceled and they
received no explanation as to why all
they were told is that this same Rover
and the instruments on it will be
included on the next mission to go so oh
don't worry this will get done it's just
that we don't have any type of future
date or planning mission of any kind on
when this will happen
and by the way this is despite an order
signed by President Donald Trump called
the space policy directive one which
involves sending humans back to the moon
and to Mars and regardless of what you
think about President Trump this is far
more than the presidents have done over
the last few decades I mean if you look
at how President Obama canceled a
mission to go back to the moon himself
he also canceled the space program in
its entirety as we now have no shuttle
mission of any kind but this isn't to
blame any specific president they're all
involved I mean even look at President
Bush before Obama how in 2006 he did
significant cuts to NASA but he himself
stated that don't worry this is going to
help get humans back to the moon by 2018
and here we are in 2018 now canceling
future missions and we have no intention
of any kind no dates like I said of
going back to the moon and this goes
further back than President Bush even
look at President Clinton look at the
date on this 1995 and now Clinton
reduced NASA's funding and you can even
find articles about this from 1981 going
back to President Reagan are you guys
starting to see a pattern here
oh we're gonna go we're gonna go we're
gonna go and they just keep canceling it
canceling it and canceling it and here
we are in 2018 and we have no dates or
mission of any kind to send even a rover
to the freaking moon and this is despite
outstanding questions that still exists
about
including the origins of it and how just
a year ago scientists have discovered
that the age of the moon is
significantly older than they ever
thought possibly older than our solar
system itself and you may have heard me
discuss in other videos other unusual
things about our Moon such as the fact
that they have discovered uranium 236 as
well as neptunium 237 which has never
been found naturally on earth so this of
course raises many questions also the
topic of lunar transient phenomena which
is something that most people have never
even heard of and this dates back a
couple thousand years even where people
have witnessed lights flashing on the
moon of different colors not just white
red but also green this photo right here
just so you know is from Columbia
University in fact this was even
witnessed by the Apollo 11 astronauts on
their way to land on the moon for the
very first time basically what happened
was back here on earth through
telescopes we observed green fluorescent
lighting on the moon as we were
approaching it for landing and when NASA
called out to the astronauts they got an
immediate response from Michael Collins
indicating that they had seen this as
well now one explanation is that this
could be volcanic activity of some kind
but it does raise questions on why green
lights have been observed but we do know
that there is volcanic activity with
inside the moon and our seismographs
that we a place there have indicated
moon quakes which raises many questions
I mean is the moon not dead after all
and this of course ties into how so many
people believe that we never went to the
moon at all and it's a pretty high
percentage of people it's larger than
most people realize and this is
something that I'll definitely have to
make a video on in the future I'm gonna
have to spend some time doing a lot of
research to really dig into it people
need to realize that not everything's
black and white it's not necessarily
about have we been there have we not
been there I think the real questions
are what did we find there and when is
the last time we have been there I mean
there are some weird things about the
Apollo missions and although I think
that we went to the moon we have to ask
ourselves why on earth denisa delete the
Apollo 11 tapes of its trajectory and
they said that back in the 80s due to
budget cuts they had to essentially
reuse the tapes but it's like wait a
second you deleted the Apollo 11 tapes
on us going to and from the moon you
couldn't find any other tape to delete
so you're like okay this just delete the
tapes and of all
very first moon mission of people
landing there ever that doesn't really
make sense and when you also combine it
to like I've discussed in other videos
the Apollo 11 press conference which was
the most Awkward thing you've ever seen
in your life go watch this on YouTube by
the way where the astronauts were just
man they just seemed depressed and just
not wanting to be there it was the most
unenthusiastic thing I've ever seen so
let's get back to NASA management and
how we're just not going back there
because we can debate the moon missions
till they're blue in the face and again
I'll make a video on that in the future
who is NASA management's right now we'll
look at Jim Brennan Stein who is
appointed by President Trump and what I
didn't realize by reading all these
articles about this cancelled Rover
mission is that this guy just assumed
office a week ago today April 23rd 2018
but yet when you look at when these
articles came out look at that April
27th so this guy takes his position on
the Monday and then by Friday the
mission had been completely dumped and
canceled his first week on the job which
I thought was incredible and then I dug
well a little bit deeper and I
discovered that wait the people on this
mission within NASA were told on the
23rd that the mission had been scrapped
and it wasn't until the 27th that the
headlines in the you know had made the
news so the very first day this guy's on
the job and despite Trump's signing a
bill to instruct NASA to go put humans
on the moon and all of a sudden he just
scraps it entirely and the scientists
themselves weren't even given an
explanation
who is this guy well it turns out that
he is a politician and I had no idea
that there was so much controversy when
this guy came on board I never even
heard that he came on board but people
were griping about how well yeah he's a
politician and there were some
interesting things that when they were
overlooking his appointment he had
deleted his YouTube Facebook and Twitter
accounts all while he was being looked
into so this guy's shady President Trump
if you're the real deal wanting to send
us back to the moon fire this guy or at
least discuss publicly what the true
intentions are because why on earth did
this guy cancelled this mission his very
first day on the job anyways guys leave
me a comment and let me know what your
thoughts are on all of this and also hit
the like button and subscribe but I'm
Jimmy this is bright insight and I have
many more videos to come and a whole
wide variety of top
take care everybody